welcome to this video on playing Kelly
that's a new ponent ah yeah ok and a
little something that i can announce
with that video i think the worst is
over in terms of noises that my desk is
making I didn't do anything with the
microphone but with the desk aha yeah I
had just said some screws and the worst
i think is over in terms of strange
sounds ok Knight to d7 hmm that looks
wrong somehow yeah anyway probably not
so wrong that I can refute it she's six
k i'm going with Bishop d3 92 and c4 and
quickly played yeah if I go see for he
might have Queen 85 so maybe castling
first yeah then I'm going to see for
next yeah I like this is rupiah rather
nice position for white does he have
anything great yeah I don't see it
really
a bishop sometimes can be a bit off now
but doesn't seem to be a factor okay um
sg5 something that he can play I mean I
probably can just expand to him that's
just take space I won't have 95 is a
month maybe to threaten f3 oops sorry
night if five week ago g5 which is what
he wants to do anyway
I think that's not a bad idea nida
spinning good only five anyway I guess
he has to go g5 I mean Bishop f7 looks
wrong then I have three and what funded
what kind of moved is 95 it cannot be
right so he will go g5 and I'm dropping
back really okay okay thinking be should
be five isn't that good that good for me
that I allowed to do this it seems nice
okay bit surprised by many moves here
but okay looking a bit at f5 and Margie
for and what then G 493 but I don't
really have to I don't need to care
about that the queen is so terrible on
g6 system you can never play the F porn
you can never play the G porn I don't
need to do anything dramatic here like
g4 moves like that
yeah that's nice control I can just open
up the be found really what I mean that
was good probably anyway and giving me
that completely I mean what that sounds
that seems really strange I asked to go
back and now I can just take f5 and porn
or Bishop Paul i guess it's there a way
to trap that Queen it doesn't have many
squares probably not but it's not
necessary to worry about that the main
danger here is that I'm screwing
something up on time the position is so
good it sound difficult to to really
throw it away okay so when he six he
didn't play a six himself for whatever
reason now i'm crashing through on the
queenside
check swage form is there's some says
some threat or
who gave to h4 Bishop f1 traps the Queen
check check check yeah it's just a queen
and the queen is nice to have especially
if the other guy doesn't matter Queen
designs well the somewhat strange game
really have to say it like that for some
reason I don't have on to examine mode
here why is that the decimal switch that
off that's strange okay anyway let's
have a look there I didn't I didn't I
hit water examine mode on very weird so
let's get rid of that ok so my line
against the Dutch in 97 Netflix someone
wrong but maybe I cannot exploit it yeah
what has to get the C porn into the game
this is why I play 92 now not if I'm
kind of skeptical about that it loses
time and it's not clear that it really
helps like a lot yeah it it gets strange
from here I think here I mean why is he
not just taking on g3 is there something
particularly wrong with it I mean this
I'm gonna move like this I don't know
seems ok I would have considered that
one also and thought that I mean I maybe
have f4 but my pawn structure is a good
weekend so it was ok for black i believe
and here i'm not sure when this looks
better also that was mysterious why not
greene takes connecting looks looks like
a normal move no he did they did that
and here i well that that just as good
for whiter I'm controlling that e5
square i'm pushing f3 so until just
playing on the queenside and yeah there
was we had no idea what this movie is
about i mean g4s super office it was an
idea anyway because i've been that
diagonal yeah and i just complete win
there's nothing nothing much the same
chang had many many possible wins yeah
you play down that a little bit little
bit to relax there i think this is this
is all ok if it takes with the Queen
here um yeah again should be five why
does someone better here he should take
on g3 it's just a mistake to not take
them take the bishop you should take
that that chance that you can get the
bishop pair that does really really
useful ok well thanks for watching